[Applause]
[Music]
Belarus is not only considered the last
dictatorship in Europe but is also the
last country in Europe in which the
death penalty still applies
it is also a place where you can be
riding quietly on a plane and suddenly
in the middle of the flight it turns
back so that the FSB the former Russian
KGB yes you heard that correctly stops
entrepreneurs who have not towed the
line all thanks to Alexander Lukashenko
himself this man has been presiding over
the country since 1994 that's more than
25 years it's quite an achievement for
an independent candidate who boasts
about not having any political party
behind him since 1992 and that is
because the party is basically himself
Lukashenka's thirst for power
it seems infinite this apprentice an
heir to the worst political control
mechanisms of the former Soviet Union
does not seem to have any intention of
leaving it has already been announced
that he will run for his riri reelection
in 2020 after overwhelming success in
the 2019 legislative elections to give
you an idea of his dominance of the 110
members of the Belarusian House of
Representatives the opposition 1-0 seats
[Music]
yep that's correct zero I mean why
bother even keeping up appearances at
this point
the result was 89 independent supporters
of Luke & Schanker and 21 deputies
divided between parties that surprise
surprise also supported Lukashenko I
mean come on he really did win in the
purest Kim jong-un style due to events
like this and also of course because of
repression political persecution
abductions violations of freedom of
expression and human rights there can be
no doubts that Belarus is a dictatorship
with all of the consequences
a dictatorship that has very strong
historical ties to Russia and we're not
only talking about the similarities
between the regimes political and modus
operandi but also a common culture
history and even linguistic heritage
that's why today in this video we're
gonna talk about what has been a curious
international romance and which is now
going through a bit of a rough patch
Belarus and Russia are like a couple
maternally engaged ins on the verge of
getting married but he seemed to be
regretting it all at the last minute
once I know more about this crazy story
let's get into it
[Music]
Belarus stuck between two opposing sides
if there's one thing that's clear in
Belarus it's that it's geopolitical
situation is extremely complicated we're
talking about a country wedged between
two powerful bloc's hostile to each
other the European Union and Russia
on the one hand Mother Russia has been
the country's livelihood since its
independence from the Soviet Union
basically on the international scene
lukashenka's Belarus as effectively
functioned as a satellite state of
Russia on the other hand the European
Union has for many years been very harsh
and critical over the regime for its
repression and lack of freedom and
democracy
[Music]
an example of this repression would be
the disappearances in 1999 and 2000 of
two opposition politicians and
entrepreneur are in a journalist which
caused the EU to impose economic
sanctions and trade restrictions on
Belarus and no don't sit for a second
that Lukashenko is a guy who likes to
disguise his authoritarian branch quite
the opposite in fact he even likes to
make jokes about it like this one from a
2012 interview for Reuters I in the last
dictator in Europe in fact there is no
other one around the world you came here
and you've seen a live dictator where
else could you see one Alexander
Lukashenko however despite Lukashenka's
strong character the truth is that in
the last four years there has been some
improvements in relations between
Belarus and the European Union we are
talking about some improvement which for
example led to the European Union's
withdrawal of sanctions against three
companies and 170 senior officials or
people close to the regime in 2016 ok
it's true there are still other
sanctions in place such as the embargo
on arms sales but this move was still
significant a sign that in spite of
everything there was still a chance that
things could improve in other words it
seems that the European Union has set
its policies with Belarus in what has
come to be called real politics that is
policies based purely and exclusively on
practical interests is Belarus a
dictatorship
yes that's crystal clear but the EU
getting along with this country is a
little bit like than sticking a finger
in Vladimir Putin's eye if there's one
thing the European Union is looking for
in the situation it is to try and weaken
Putin's power and influence and for the
government of Vladimir Putin Belarus is
a key country his loss strong Ally
something likes the favourite son who is
protected no matter what but who
occasionally needs some favors
that's why Putin's playing coy but the
European Union's reproach moans with
Belarus
is becoming quite a headache for him in
other words in the European Union's
relationship with Belarus the least
important thing is actually Belarus the
fact is that over the last decade trade
with the European Union has taken off
again and more importantly it should be
noted the Belarus has started to receive
EU funds specifically 110 million euros
has come from the well known European
neighbourhood instrument between 2014
and 2018 this is miniscule compared to
what Russia has given Belarus over the
years but it shows a clear improvement
in relations between Minsk and Brussels
after all there aren't so many reasons
to give away millions of euros every
year are there yes okay I know we're
talking about the European Union but
still this brings us to a key question
how exactly are relations between Russia
and Belarus nowadays remember these are
two countries that have traditionally
been closest like siblings just a few
years after the fall of the Soviet Union
they even studied their political
integration yep that's right
[Music]
progressive integration that's what
Lukashenko himself and then Russian
president Boris Yeltsin agreed on in
1999 that year they created a
supranational structure intended to
gradually integrate the two states a
structure that was dubbed the Union
state now I'm sure many of you will be
Bissell surprised to hear that someone
like Lukashenko or a guy with such great
ambition for power was willing to
integrate with Russia which let's be
clear would have kept all the power in
Moscow
[Music]
so what was it that led Lukashenko to
compromise and devise a plan to
integrate with Boris Yeltsin that he
honestly believed that Russians were
going to give him power in order to
understand Lukashenko Russia and how
this whole relationship has recently
switched gear let us explain what this
whole Union State thing was all about it
was a project so crazy that it was born
to fail the Union States the absorption
that never happened
as we just told you a moment ago this
Union State thing was something that was
agreed on in 1999 between Lukashenko and
Yeltsin at the time Yeltsin was a far
cry from Putin and Lukashenko was just
learning the ropes of being the dictator
that he is today but what were Yeltsin
and Lukashenka's real intentions when
the original agreement was made well you
see Russia basically wanted to kick NATO
in the shins because at that time NATO
had just expanded to include Poland the
Czech Republic and Hungary the expansion
allowed the North Atlantic Treaty forces
to be practically at the Russian border
Moscow needed an out-of-the-box
counter-attack the answer play their
cants too slow NATO's advance and proved
that they were still a superpower and
the counter-attack began with their
faithful Ally their blood and
ideological brother Belarus
in this way the union that was raised
created a supranational entity in which
both countries were gradually integrate
into a kind of political and economic
bloc yes theoretically both countries
would retain their political and
territorial sovereignty but decisions
about economic policy as well as foreign
policy and defense would be taken by
this new body in practice a really
strong integration was proposed and not
only that russia's vision for this union
went much further and included the
creation of a common currency a single
parliament a constitution their own
courts etc that is create a russian mega
Blok along the lines of the former
Soviet Union
however the blood brothers soon got cold
feet the pact sounded great but how
exactly would power be shared how was
this agreement in Belarus his best
interest wasn't there the obvious risk
of being taken over by their huge
neighbor well even though it seems hard
to believe it appears that in the first
instance Lukashenko blind with ambition
thought that the union could see himself
thrust into the role of leader of the
new mega block and Stasi would direct
not only the destiny of Belarus but also
of Russia itself
that is although it seems absurd the
move Lukashenko had in minds and it was
something like kind of takeover where
her little fish eats the big one
dreams are free the problem today is
that Putin is not Yeltsin and today's
Russia doesn't much resemble the Russia
in free fall of the late nineteen
nineties either in other words the
Belarusian tyrant was speaking out of
his backside
Lukashenko never managed to achieve his
goals and over the years as Vladimir
Putin consolidated his power even
further
Belarus became an increasingly isolated
economy in Europe and was totally
dependent on Russia to such an extent
that so-called Union state came to mean
only two things to the country
annexation or blackmail let me explain
for the past twenty years Russia has
used oil and natural gas sales at below
market prices to consolidate its
influence in Minsk the cost of Russia of
this policy has been high some
calculations such as those of Russian
Finance Minister Anton Siluanov point to
more than two billion dollars
[Music]
and let's see how this plays out during
this time Lukashenko has been doing
business year after year the Belarusian
economy has specialized in oil
processing refineries and fuel exports
in this way while negotiations to secure
the union state were cooling down
Lukashenko continued to take advantage
of existing agreements of course as you
can imagine there came a point where
Russia got tired of waiting without
getting anything in return you could say
the Vladimir Putin felt the Belarusians
were teasing him and as you know you
don't fool around with Putin in 2019
Moscow began to put conditions on oil
contracts in order to advance the Union
State
basically they threatened to remove
Russian oil and as Belarus started
agreeing to implements the required
steps to integration let's say Putin
said something like this
be careful Nucor behave yourself I'll
take your dinosaur juice away and then
you'll be sorry
Russia hints at Belarus joining it in a
unified state in exchange for oil deal
Lukashenko Reuters right here is when
the crisis broke out there real dogfight
between the two leaders
[Music]
the big about-face treason or fight to
survive right up until late 2019
Lukashenko could be heard saying things
like this over and over again two of us
could unite tomorrow no problem
Alexander Lukashenko however by early
2020 the rhetoric had changed quite a
bit take a look we have our own country
were sovereign and independent and we
can't be a part of some other country I
can't betray you and dissolve Belarus
even into brotherly Russia if I agree to
that Belarusians would eat me alive
within a year it's honorable to be the
first president of Belarus but I sure
don't want to be the last Alexander
Lukashenko it is as if suddenly a
nationalistic and sovereignist spirit
has been awakened in Lukashenko now is
he really serious or is it simply
strategic pressure to get more and more
concessions out of Moscow knowing the
Putin perhaps needs Belarus to keep him
in the driver's seat
oh wait why would Putin need his
neighbor to maintain his own power well
the Russian president is currently
developing several schemes to stay in
power beyond 2020 for rince one such
plan involves Belarus the scheme would
be as follows if Russia and Belarus end
up creating a new state with a new body
of governments different from that of
the current Russian Federation the
switch encompasses both countries suitum
could become presidents of that new
state as he would be subject to a new
constitution with new conditions and
with a new status power in other words
Putin would be president again but not
of the Russian Federation but of the
Union state of Russia and Belarus either
way it seems like the dispute is getting
serious
in January 22 ntil exports from russia
to belarus plummeted by 75% of what had
been forecast russia reduced deliveries
by one and a half million tons of crude
oil and as we mentioned earlier in the
Belarusian economy petrochemical
industry is very important so this is
forced Lukashenko to choose between two
paths either given to Moscow or try to
find other friends to supply the country
with all the fuel they need to prevent
the country falling apart and that's
when some new friends showed up
Belarus starts importing oil from Norway
after Russian halt business insider but
it's not just about Norway Minsk is
suddenly found another savior a country
that has not mediated diplomatically
with Belarus for 10 years and now
suddenly wants to restore diplomatic
relations back to a hundred percent any
ideas
[Music]
Pompeyo visits Belarus as Minsk ties
with Moscow Frei Reuters united states
wants to help Belarus build its own
sovereign country our energy producers
stand ready to deliver 100% of the oil
you need at competitive prices
your nation should not be forced to be
dependent on any one partner for your
prosperity or for your security Mike
Pompeo secretary of state of the United
States of America don't tell me it's not
revenue
however despite getting new suppliers
Belarus is now suffering from a pressing
oil shortage that has already led to the
suspension of petrochemical exports
exports that the country desperately
needs in order to get foreign currency
namely dollars and that's what led to
the Belarusian dictator playing one of
his last cards threatening to steal some
of his crude oil exports from Russia
taking advantage of the fact that
Russian oil exports to Europe cross
Belarusian territory and of course the
last card would be to actually steal it
Belarus threatens to siphon off Russian
oil intended for Europe al Jazeera
either way as you can see relations
between Putin and Lukashenko of volatile
I wouldn't be surprised if they were on
the verge of blocking each other on
whatsapp the Belarusians presidents is
beginning to sidle up to the west to
prevent its isolation leading to a
treaded crimean star russian invasion
which could leave them completely alone
in the world and with no one to defend
them well with no one to defend him and
his comfy reclining chair
and I'm sure you can imagine that threat
to steal Russian oil is not sitting well
with Moscow
can you imagine Putin's face if his oil
started disappearing from the pipelines
anyway these are the things which mark
the latest battle on the crazy stage of
Eastern Europe the visual politic will
be watching to see how events unfold in
the meantime what do you think of all of
this has Russia earned the right to
control its neighbor as payback for all
of the oil that it has supplied mates
rates well the Russian presidents get
away with annexing the neighbouring
country is Nuka Schenker really willing
to ally with the west well leave your
answer in the comments below and i do
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did don't
forget to subscribe don't forget to
check out our friends of the Ricans in
the media podcast thank you for watching
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider
ww re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast